so anyway I think in terms of keeping up
with what's going on in China one of the
more exciting things to me has been the
rapid increase of funding available not
only in the old traditional centers of
entrepreneurship Shanghai and Beijing
but really throughout a lot of new
regions in China and so I thought today
would be a good opportunity to explore
just what's going on with two people who
are very involved with this process so
sitting closest to me is dr. Shah Alam
and Chou is the chief fire starter and
general manager for in Oh spring Silicon
Valley and she's one of the founders of
innerspring which really is now a
shanghai-based accelerator and sauna
park manager and venture capital fund
yes and Shah has extensive health care
and health taken entrepreneurial
expertise she was a project manager a
pharmaceutical tech consulting company
in Toulouse and she's also working very
closely with the China American
innovation network a nonprofit
organization that fosters us-china
entrepreneurship and she is a member of
the Qing hua entrepreneur Executive Club
and president of the Qing hua Alumni
Association of Northern California so
we're happy to have Xiao next to Xiao is
George Chow who is co-founder of the
Silicon Valley innovation and
entrepreneurship forum forum and he
comes from the clean tech and high-tech
manufacturing industries he's assisting
companies and finding capital resources
and developing business strategies with
a focus on those two areas high tech in
manufacturing he was with the Green Tech
Power Group previously which is
developing a utility-scale solar
technologies he's also worked closely
with UC Berkeley and Lawrence Berkeley
National Labs since spent six years of
an icy design engineer at LBL
and is vice president of the Berkeley
Chinese Alumni Association International
Association so we're delighted to have
both of our panelists with us each
panelist is going to give some comments
we'll talk a little bit to get
discussion going and then we'll open it
up to audience Q&A so George if you'll
go first that's great sure thank you
Richard for the introduction so again my
name is George chow I'm the co-founder
of the Silicon Valley innovation spoon
or thorne
yeah so I want to thank everybody for
coming I know it's actually almost final
times so you guys are getting pcs for
your final exam and I saw that and then
and also so how many of us we have
started your company okay just few I'm
going to hope you plan to start your
company after the fact okay great
oh okay good good yeah if you actually
want to focus more on Asia okay thank
you guys come to this kind of event so I
hope I I was assuming you guys might be
interesting a lot of Asia so uh so again
um I actually I expect from the school
the other table debate and then it's
like I remember sitting in this kind of
bathroom and then you know actually I
thought I thought it is Berkeley
actually no we all know Eclipse here so
so how many of you actually know ages
okay good yes it's the Asia Pacific
students intrapreneurs society group so
I think also which was like the divisor
yes so so I think I like HS cannot
inspire my spoon or chip and then so
after great aunt Berkeley I went to go
to a national lab and then and then
Steven Chu your I think physics head I
think went to Berkeley Lab and become
the director and then a so he kind of
mentor a few of us and after that I
start my own solar company and then I
also I started this Silicon Valley
Richard small forum in 2011 so that's
how we see you know there are almost
cartridge
which US and China and so we thought
this group kind of like to have you know
more and more collaborations between US
and China
you know both company wise and also all
big boys so maybe next step so so here
you know for the past seven years so we
are first year we have Bill Clinton into
our events and then I outdoor and then
you know ashton culture and steve
wozniak we have you know fuels on both
political and also on many successful
CEO explores come to our event and also
many of the chinese company like show me
the field like jeering and also stephen
to be across from the IPO lab how many
people can to are even kinda like to
share more you know how how can use in
china can i collaborate more together
because we we believe you know
collecting a room where you can put you
know both the private sector and also
government and also our investors
together you can we can make this work
better so maybe your next slide and also
we have this kind of like you look like
the vif star contest like kind of like
our our our USB is start so we actually
have many companies to me you know to
our comcast so every year you to the end
of September we have this compact at the
company center usually wore pink so we
will get anywhere between you know 100
250 companies to me to us and then we
will probably join down to 20 and then
we will have this contest at the
community center and also like for the
one on the left is the alternative
seeing our fifth start star contest and
then the one on the on the right is our
last year and also we gave like the top
30 Innovation Awards you know at our our
convention and in there was the one on
the last bottom is actually just
happened recently the Chinese the
mixture of science that you can to us
they want us to host this you know
starts the competition for them so
actually they have three locations they
have one in Houston and then one in here
and then one after here is Boston so
they stay to these three cities Rochelle
and they go to China and they go to like
Hangzhou Beijing
and in Shanghai and also sent the few
cities to do that so we do all these
kind of competitions now to help you
know many of the entrepreneurs here to
connect back to China so next and so so
here I just feel the you know opponent
we have here and also as you can see
some like the thorax and also definitely
many of the Berkeley launch and also sky
back and then also many of the last
actually so a lot many of them came to
us to become the judge and also they
also refer yourself to our competition
to Carol I too could do that so next and
so so today you know our car i we want
to talk about you know few cities so we
kind of picked a few cities so so the
first one is it's a good so those
sensors actually dependent government
came to us so last year they actually
host I think that the the first one
actually ever kind of did a big contest
they actually have this contest in six
continents so I can us who kind of hosts
their us competition site and then if
Japan is Tokyo and EV Israel and they
have Australia and as Europe and Germany
and also they have some in China so
basically each reaching they will pick
you know ten or twenty 20 companies as
you tend ten companies and slide
everybody back to and done and in the
top 60 they will pick the top three and
they actually gave you you know cash no
string attached you don't need to move
there you don't have to give them equity
they basically just gave you free money
if you want the contest and it also
definitely if you decide to locate there
of course if they have office you know I
can give you office space they also have
both public and private ventures that I
came back in to you so this all second
year actually working with the day
actually make it like a TV show so I
should be still so this year we had a
actually so we had our Simpson
competition March 19th actually I was
wrong it was clear and so we we we had
some winners by their I think one of
them is the Stanford company they are
the 3d ceramic company so actually went
back and then actually day one one of
the war so so this is kinda like the
April 14 there
the competition in Fenton so those are
the judges
actually they model Minh is actually a
lung disease in the middle is George
smooth he's actually a Nobel Prize
winner out of Lawrence Berkeley National
Lab he won the Nobel Prize 2016 so he's
in physics so he cannot judge you know
that
and so the bottom lab is kind of like
older all the winners which they won
like we went to the point of the final
contest and then on the on the right
bottom essentially they met with the in
the middle if you see it they met with
the mayor of census so so they kind of
like on you know do this because I'm
trying to see you know trying to get the
best talents for all the world not just
the US but everywhere of the world's you
to test and so they can you know can I
have the best because you know since
then they call themself kinda Silicon
Valley of China so like they want more
company to go there and into a pond or
with them and if you even if you are
hardware or anything like a sentence big
for how we're and they would like to
help you enjoy Inventure with many other
you know companies in China and do that
so so there's definitely famous for that
and then the next time and then so so
the at the beginning of this month so
from May 10th and soft so we also have
our can do events so this is our second
year doing the sandal event so we have
about 10,000 people there and then as
you can see the actually is part of it
as part of their global innovation spoon
or forum also and so we have we flying
many of the US you know companies also
other the also razor he's also like
another Nobel Prize winner and also Jack
McCauley he's the co-founder of oculus
and then and also I think field of
Berkeley and several professors there
enough points on all ships so they want
to kind of inspire more entrepreneurship
and also telephone companies there so
also if you can see on the actually on
the right hand side on the top so we
actually we actually flying about 90
startup companies so so they can pitch
event also we give them like 101
matching so they can meet many of the
maze Aquino for investors there and also
allows the companies who want to invest
to them so so that that's not on the
dyno track so he's actually pitching so
basically we had we gave them with like
ten or fifteen people try to they can
pitch at the circumference so they can
you know have many of the investors I
think our goal is to read to bring you
know companies you know here to today we
say you know you can if you start your
company here you can still stay here so
you know you want to also look into
China to see where if you can find any
financing or any strategic partners we
think you can do parallel honest you
don't have to just to stick in the US
and also to write in to both both ways
especially you know so that's that and
also as you can see on the on the bottom
left so that's kinda like our Expo like
people we brought about 90 companies
there they all showcase you know they're
you know drones robotic nori is and also
all they're kinda like their toys as
they come up with the companies with so
they can actually showcase all their
companies there and then I think they
are like ten thousand people there is
actually like you look at the middle
actually it's the governor of Sichuan
province Ely so like so like he actually
is showcasing you know the wearable so
like the the guy with the glass is name
is Steve May so he's kind like the
father of wearable so he came out with
his own wearable device are you are
showing a needy on that and so I'm the
right-hand side to the company that you
see there to showcase different things
so we want you to actually able to
showcase you know all the things that
you have here like we want YouTube you
can come with us and actually go to like
you know showcase your products you know
with with your your role map and all
that with many of the companies in China
so that's that connect with the goal for
flower or events communiques yeah and
also so also the other one is its young
actually so I didn't do so I know
actually I talked with many of the
speakers and also stock companies when
and he said they were saying that you
know they think can do it's a really new
city we saw the new infrastructure and
we saw the collected a new high tech
stuff they really enjoyed it actual all
of the company founders home ESG they
they won't mind actually a stay there
and also this
or a year or two because you know they
actually they enjoy a CD they think the
infrastructure is pretty new and we saw
the new buildings and also music or the
new technology they have there so they
really enjoyed it so so and at the end
the other city is young so she is we
know it's kind of like a historical like
a city right so many you know like the
terracotta warriors you know the
soldiers so actually so the Sheung
government they know they have all the
history or the tourism right so this is
so they kind of want to think about what
you do with the estate right and so they
see all the toys and I they have here so
they think you know definitely like
we're both or anything way to connect
and help their city especially with the
new what belt one Road right it's
actually started young so they've been
looking at you know few different things
and what they can do we chose a new new
technology they can have so we we also
hosted the event they're talking about
like you know deep learning and then
innovation and also many of the company
also pitch their connection they want to
focus on both you know AR VR and also
anything really to collect the travel
and also all of the collector finance
those are areas that I think tank
because those are the areas space that's
the government government told us you
know hey those are the areas they are
they're looking at especially we were at
the new new technology development
center place so like that's how I do a
new industry center and all that so what
I see actually so for you know I think
different CD I think definitely China
you know like Center in definitely you
know if you want to go for all hours and
also all those I think are there
definitely innovation they are
definitely happy having a lot of those
because I think they are also the first
mover as we come to Silicon Valley
having their own different incubators
here and also on many of the mentally
have several integrators here actually
they want to link between know both US
and China and also can do is as we
mentioned you know they are a pretty big
city in China and then they are
definitely on the you know West and then
they definitely want to know more people
there and
many of the fortune 500 companies are
there and they are also looking for
companies with a camp where they can
partner with and also two more so that's
definitely the area that is very
interesting and then Gianna again if we
talk like it's a historical city with
other you know for the history and all
that so if anybody's interested more
about history you know so that you know
that can be a great city to to living
where you can know to both citizens and
also to oral the city with all the
historical stuff so so this happened
like the few areas that that we we we
focus on yeah
and so George is this your final slide
yeah okay so while I'm going to set up
for shallow slides can I ask you a
follow up is this central government
money that goes to the cities for them
to develop the way that they want to I
mean bringing large numbers of startup
companies from Silicon Valley over is a
pretty expensive thing so do you know if
it's central money or is it money that's
really from the province and staying in
the province or I think it's on the
province
I don't know again am I going to fit but
not one of them is taking a different
angle yet on entrepreneurship exactly
yeah yeah so they typically they want us
to bring you know both like the speakers
and also many of the US companies there
and also many of the US companies will
take in coming in actually experience
you know how the cities subside and also
you know all the intrapreneurship
ecosystem is like and so that's that's
you're wasting most of the securities
yeah okay which one of actually contact
us you know like old differently writing
like I won't want to see see how you
know each city can use their own
strengths to kind like to get the right
you know like that yeah okay so it's
really there's a sense of competition
between the cities yato like you're in
competition think I know there's always
competition yeah sure okay so what's why
don't you have a sweet and shall I think
we're ready for your comment
okay well thanks for trevor first of all
for inviting me
last time i spoke at the campus was a
couple years ago yeah it was we were
talking about new trends and
acceleration with yeah yeah where our
business mala has evolved so much and
I'm glad that Gert my friend over here
spoken about a lot of different options
in China and our businesses actually
really go deep and figuring out what are
the differences between out of the
cities and why these things matters to
you because we're all here from the
folly and I think the issue isn't lack
of choices if the issue is having a lot
of options but how do you know which one
fit for you I think that's what's really
interesting so I'm going to start with
telling our story of where we started
and what we are who we are today
and then slowly into our business models
that could perhaps help you sort out
some of that questions let's get started
so I want to start with this light
because I always wanted to start with a
slide I talked about megatrend I want to
know you know this slides basic tall
stories of the fact that half of the
largest internet companies that is in
history comes from China that started
with no connection to Silicon Valley and
that might not be news to you because
I've seen a lot of Asian faces in the
audience but this is probably not
something that everyone in the new u.s.
north and if you think about and dig
into the stories of why half of them
started and they were able to make it
become some of them are actually bigger
than their counterparts in the US and
how do they make it to today and there's
a lot of interesting stories and a lot
of that is definitely related to the
booming technology hotspot in China and
the support and the energy they were
able to get from China so that would be
an interesting thought but I'll come
back to the site later
so essentially what we're trying to say
is China itself is a magical place I
mean our headquarter is in Shanghai we
are looking at the Pro Tower anyone
knows the Pearl Tower the signature
place in Shanghai we are across the
river from that you would consider it
one of the hotspot in Shanghai because
we're paying expensive rent but under
we're at a 20-story building where we're
sitting at an 11th floor and what five
minutes walk from our office I can lead
you to them one of the most expensive
restaurant in Shanghai you will love it
you think Shanghai would be you know the
best place ever you have a great service
great experience but I can also spend
another 3 minutes across suite and
showing something that is a terrible
experience you will hit it whenever go
back to China again so this is really
how complicated China can be right next
door to our building that is a small
section of rural old buildings that were
tear down 50% but not completely a tear
down it's been around because of the
messy lost you the government had with
the resident over there that has been
there for 50 years you see something
that you probably see you don't you
wouldn't imagine to see in downtown
Shanghai so try to really complicated to
figure it out and I think the mission of
our company is help you guys to navigate
it is a little bit easier and this is
where we started but I just want to give
you a really big trend here so China
today has a lot of resources for
start-up so we're finally evolving from
a state-owned government dictated
economy to today we're building and
promoting an open innovation system so
the government has committed 300 billion
u.s. dollars in the next 10 years
dedicated into investing in startups
I think this amount of infrastructure is
what we haven't seen any
on a planet this is what we call strong
from bad room Coney Island room function
it's something that the government start
promoting two years and one two years
ago actually and there are already close
to 3,000 incubators nationwide in China
and almost like Starbucks and this is
what I'm trying to say you consider
China the problem is you have a lot of
options and what's challenging is how do
you figure out who to work with that's
always going to be challenging okay but
the reason why we're all talking about
China I think last time I was there I
start with a slide say China is the only
interesting story we're talking about
right now that's different I remember
sitting at conferences of VCS that set
off stage the only interesting thing
that they talk about is all Chinese
economy is slowing down China is
different and there's always interesting
story that come out of that but the
amount of the growth rate that Chinese
American companies was finally achieving
like uber did was something that blew
their mind even today even with
everything we talk about and think about
China
we still underestimate how big China
market can be so I have a friend who sit
on the board of Ober what they've
achieved in two years in terms of the
rat growth curve it's fundamentally all
heard of compared to anywhere else so
for a long time for a decade companies
are struggling with the idea of saying
thinking that none of the American
companies would ever capture Chinese
market and value this is what a lot of
Giants have tried but when we were tried
it again without help they didn't do it
John Victor didn't try to collaborate
locally to start they did it themselves
independently in two years they invested
a billion dollars they're losing money
everywhere but after they were merged
with DD their stake
a is still worth 7 billion dollars that
is at least 3x gain in two years in big
numbers it's not something you can use
it again anywhere so so this is why
Chinese market is still magical there
are still a lot of potential value but
the problem is who can win there and
even the big companies like Google has
tried and failed so that's really
interesting so before I go into the corn
please more details I all want to show
this this is something my team member
had taught me where I'm looking at this
chart I found it on the Internet this
one shows the amount of patent that's
being filed in different countries if
you look at the US and blue versus China
look at how much of the number of patent
has grown from China in recent years it
is growing exponentially so the image of
China where China is just copying
somebody else's technology is completely
changing its changing under Arita it's
changing even without me knowing I only
find out about this a few months ago and
Chinese company is slowly being
innovative and I think that's why a lot
of there's a lot of people a lot of
company getting scared but the more
Chinese company is changing the more I
think we should seriously thinking about
the question and a way to go to China
next one so this is also something
interesting I want to talk about how
many so when you have about Chinese GDP
use economy everybody knows is a big
number right but this is the interesting
question what shares of Chinese growth
industry output do you think come from
state-owned enterprises can anybody take
a guess how much of the Chinese TDT
comes from the state-owned and it's
enterprises how much is coming from
private can anyone take a guess
what is that could be 30 good okay 30%
for the SOS or for the private okay
somebody else you could get I'm going to
be 30 seconds this is not my research
this is the skies research the famous
book market so Vermeil rise of prices is
a child as I read it so any much
interest it can go but I can tell you
the answer the answer is the opposite of
what you just said only 25% very
tremendous sale which is in my mind I
cannot make this out five years ago but
it's true it's somebody else research
that means China is restructuring itself
and it's happening in and seeing and
seeing rate next one so everybody is
talking about Chinese economy is slowing
down I think our current target is what
five to six percent that's what we want
to get down to but with the huge problem
with roaring cost as problem with cystic
not not able to sustain growth in the
traditional industry sector like
construction like power like
manufacturing China is facing a critical
time of restructuring in their
industrial output from traditional
industry to technology and even would
slow down target of growth of 5.5
percent every year we're still looking
at about three to five trillion and
market size that we need to achieve in
technology sector alone and that is a
huge amount of huge number so it's so
got a lot of opportunity there so and
most of that is in the private sector so
it's actually a good market and the
primed to be interrupt for of time to be
disrupt for our innovation technologies
okay so now I want to talk about like
what we do who we are so I think a last
time I visited the campus also talking
about our local business the Silicon
Valley branch so we
started with building the first us-china
technology incubator and we started in
2011 and were one of the first ones that
actually shout out the US China flag and
trying to encourage people to think
about China and I still remember when I
joined a company in 2012 when we go out
and talk to founders we talk to a lot of
people and we were marketing a China
strategic directions we were offering
our technique in the medics / teas in
the China market most of the response I
got were from people who rode their eyes
and saying we're not going to think
about China and five to ten years
we're probably think about it when we
raise seriously money that is probably
sixty percent of people would say to me
but after Alibaba went IPO in 2013 China
was sort of reintroduced to us and
things just look and now we're hearing
people talking about starting a business
here dedicated for China and you know it
hasn't been that long
so we decided that we were on something
that was real business even though at a
time we had a small incubator we thought
we're going to become a Y Combinator and
turn out we will never become Y
Combinator we have to become something
that we focused on the us-china growth
so that's why we also change ourselves
next one here's who we are today
so we decided to really incorporate
ourselves as a real cross-border
platform and today we have nine
co-founders I've got one of my close
learners right there Michael he doesn't
visit me that often because he was
working really hard over there and then
we have today 80 employees and because
we've been in the industry of hopping
startup to break into complicated
technology ecosystem for last 15 years
initial a fortune wha
now we've become independent
and today weld is served for years
helping startups across three name
industries that we focus on smart
systems life sciences and smart
construction and we expand with
operation in three countries with two
offices in the US five offices in China
and one we're setting it up in Germany
and when we run across four we see funds
in six core two locations and here's
what we have a chief I think in short of
three and a half years we were able to
achieve five IPO through our past
connections of serving them and today
serving only 300 companies but together
they're worth already four billion
dollars that's not something we thought
we could achieve is actually helpful
working a lot faster than we think it
could and there's a reason for that next
one I thought it would be interesting to
compare us with Y Combinator because
once we started I was obsessed with
actually trying to figure out how we
could draw analogy there not certainly
much much smaller in scale and shorter
and years of operation but I think we
we've done ok the path IPOs are they
here in China they are mostly all in
China and also okay okay here's our
operations I want to show this map not
just to show where we are in operations
I'll also show you why we pick the
Shanghai area specifically because when
Richard told me about today's subject
was talking about innovation hotspot
other than Beijing and Shanghai that
would make it really interesting and I'm
glad that George has taken a lot of
business cities that you could be going
into but we pick two cities one is
Quincy on one essential how many of you
have heard of these two cities oh there
are actually people heard of that okay
good probably with you okay
I want to tell you some stories and with
them worked we've done in these two
cities and the reason that is next slide
because the only thing about this
and it's really interesting to see
what's behind the technology hotbar how
many of you thinking that technology hot
bug is by design that it started first
then it helps great company to spend out
of there or how many of you think
thinking that started probably on its
own and just scale them they're really
like thinking about this book how did
things start from 0 to 1 how did things
start from 0 to 1 since Beijing tech
community just start on its own or
something else magical happens and I
don't have an answer for that we are
trying to do our business is actually
from 0 to 1 our business is to figure
out how to do a tech spot and
entrepreneurship ecosystem in a scalable
way the scalable approach to quickly
leapfrog in certain industries where
everybody we work with every startup we
serve can grow much faster with us
instead of becoming independent that is
the core of our business next I want to
tell you one of the story of conscience
Corey Allen is actually very close to
Shanghai it's 18 minutes by train right
now an hour by driving it's 40 minutes
from the poodle Airport but you probably
haven't heard of that Queen Jennah
always got 1.6 million people and it's
got 300 billion RMB and GDP it's the
richest non first year city in China
it's something that's been ignored but I
want to tell you what we did in Clinton
in the last eight years so next slide
in 2007 that's when we decided to start
a life science park there why is that
close to Shanghai people are educated
it's got a lot of space for lab work and
it's close to universities around
Shanghai and sudo and then gee it's
really good location but in
you saw the seven least start at there's
zero life science there and what's
happening today after ten years in we
only have two key companies but together
we have 10 candidate drugs in clinical
trials they're all original science six
of them are in space we four out of six
our class 1.1 drugs how many of you
knows what the class 1.1 means class 1.1
means its original research that doesn't
exist anywhere else on a planet its
original its new it's from China that
alone of managing will believe that I
could happen when I had a conversation
with a guy who runs the UCSF Innovation
Center I told him we have a live Science
Park he look at me he said oh yeah you
guys just do medical device and copycats
he said that to my face I told him I
have four class one point one in space
read he said now I said now he then took
his hat off and said you have taught me
something I don't know about China and
surprise me thank you
we have four class one and one in face
rate I can tell you what it means in
China in the last thirty years people
have been developing the health care
life science industry how many of class
one point one drug that was the proof do
you think that exists in China how many
do you think that exists first of all
define class one point class one is
original candidates original science
that's never been commercialized
anywhere where to first
okay okay and you know clinical trials
phase one is a few dozen people phase
two is several hundred people phase
three is in the tens of thousands of
people who are attempting you know the
drug is being tested so yes they made an
average cost R&D is two hundred million
million dollars not expose right yes
yeah so usually success in Phase two is
time's a startup company here gets
bought why Rocher pies are one of the
other Giants right
okay just pour that back just that face
to the background yeah there's only one
given all that dollar spend in China
probably trillions of dollars spent in
the entire industry
there's wannabe in the proof and the
company's the work should keep Gilligan
with one we have four in favorite it's
something that's unimaginable that we've
created in turn how do we do that
it's really I was really fascinated
because every time it had a story people
were will then the life science industry
always want to know it's impossible but
it is possible
okay next one so I'll tell you how do we
do it we don't believe in supporting
startup one by one if you think about
how do we saw a way to build a system
that really support a lot of companies
with solving their commonly seen
challenges is the key scale in
innovation systems and this is example
of us helping this technology when we
were one vertical in life science called
ironing AI technology it's a it's
technology that was discovered about 50
years ago the guy who originated and
found it with the word as a Nobel Prize
so we have both a open innovation system
something that you heard a lot in
Silicon Valley where in your naval
corporation research labs and public
platform this is color coding blue green
and great and enable all of them work
that these are the bestest best
resources that is available in country
or in the world that we help them
actually bring them here all together
that supports fundamental research all
the way to new drug development so
systematically they solve every
company's pain points that's what we've
done
inclusion that's the foundation of
driving results we spent 10% of money
investing in this compared with our
actually competition in Shanghai Jong
Hyun and sudo we have this and they have
none
so that's the difference so just that
way next one thank you
so basically we were thinking about this
from outside n when we look at this we
look at a systems problem how do you
just help with a hundred companies
because the odds of success in life
science is five to ten percent how do
you beat other people no one is
everybody is as smart you can't be
smarter you probably can only be smarter
with somebody else if there's a really
huge difference there it's really hard
the only way to beat everybody else and
to increase your office success is
having this way to solve knowledge
technology and market innovation
altogether so that's basically we've
done in the life science industry next I
want to show you sighs oh this is I
forgot um so this is something that I
think it's one of the interesting ideas
that we've done last year that speaks to
how we connect collaborate with you guys
so quark pharmaceuticals is the Bay Area
based pharmaceutical company and two
years ago we decided enter into a joint
venture with them with one of our
company that we invested in China Cory
ball is a pharmaceutical company they
both spend a lot of R&D dollars Ribble
at a time I've spent about $100 and then
quark spent about 300 million dollars in
US and they both want global market but
they both constrained with resources
time and money to actually enter into
their perspective content parts the way
we work is we did a joint venture to put
compounds all together into one company
and we share market and we were able to
push one of the core pharmaceutical
candidate drugs from preclinical to
space rate in a year and a half and a
year a half a time is plenty of
companies valuation so it's really
innovative way to help their companies
to success a disk feed this is like a
good way to actually work with Bay Area
companies next so next I want to tell
you another story about this new city
Continental
if you notice that we don't really take
Beijing and Shanghai that is because we
take in areas where we think there's
still empty room for us to play in but
the way we do it is always focus on
vertical integration of an industry so
because we realize that when founders
think about going into China they don't
think about having too much too many
options they think about what do I want
the most I go to China for commercial
value don't we
so because China is a big market I have
technology I think I can have customers
what I think about is not because the
city has probable having good food is
important but most important is I could
easily find finding I can find people I
can find customers and hopefully I can
do that a cheap as possible so this in
the city we Vegas meant always got a
hundred billion construction market size
that's 40 percent of what you can have
in China it's very unique places Kwan's
world as been missing but nobody really
is working there and it's an hour away
I'm sure hi so we decided to do
something really innovative next slide
everybody's talking about Internet of
Things but without existing market value
Internet of Things rule really won't
materialize so we decided to do a smart
constructive smart City Science Park in
mentem the layer on a huge 100 billion
construction market there are buyers of
technology they're just there they have
cash there are two traditional they have
no idea how software works we decided to
help them to visualize it intelligent
smart cheap greener building an entire
ecosystem and help them commercialize
and integrate with technology so these
technology could come to us and talk to
40% of all construction buyers anywhere
in China so this is will be done
actually Michael is he's in charge of
this
so anybody interested next one anyway so
this is the ecosystem we both all the
way from understanding what founders
want from ideation from building
prototypes for having actual product
that works to showcase your customers
from running business
and contest mentorship all the way of
funding and talking to all of the local
68 industry alliances our buyers so this
is the ecosystem next this is some of
the biggest names in a construction
industry in home and they're there
they're part of this Expo system that we
have
so it's just a way that we can help
really scale from zero to one how an
industry and technology hotspot whatever
works so that's pretty much close to the
answer
good so why don't charge come up come
back up let's talk for a little bit so
shall one thing that I kind of got lost
in your presentation if I'm a startup
company here in Silicon Valley why would
I call in a spring if you're in the
industry that we already have okay okay
and so in that regard I would be
interested in getting into China yeah
you may interested in go to China you
are in an energy of smart systems no
manufacturing construction smart city
okay I like scientists okay we are a
top-notch in China we can't say and
other industries we will be competitive
but in those three yeah you know with Y
Combinator you put in your proposal and
you pitch and so forth and maybe you get
in right but what you're doing is really
network throughout China and is a much
different kind of engagement yes we're
trying to cut the business value chain
and offer that to founders entrepreneurs
because we realize we can't compete with
Y Combinator here but we can compete
with all that and our connections
combine okay
so same thing George when a company
would come to you is they would be
interested in some of the programs that
you're doing some of the travel to China
that you're organizing why tis a company
here a startup company here come - yeah
so basically I think was so we have you
know relationship with the Tendo
government also sensor and also
the Xian government obviously they
specific hold on saying is that the
industry that were interested you know
like a new material like health care and
then magnified other batch manufacturing
you know those areas so basically we we
we can you okay so what kind of mistakes
are sorta Valley startup companies
making when they think about China
George you first I think for them you
know they they think you know they just
go with us go there and then I and then
they can start really well in there but
you know in China usually when you go
there you know you get to know each
other and then then you get you get to
know the business China and all that you
learn that you know as you go and then
and so that's actually we tell them you
know it takes time to develop a
relationship and also you know we can
help you facilitate you know the we saw
the government relations or that but
still I didn't know their you know it
takes take take some time to touched on
yeah okay sure
biggest mistake I think are either
people think China is impossible to them
and there's no there's no reason to
think about it I think that's one of the
biggest mistake the other one is
thinking China is just about cheap
funding Dom funding quote-unquote yeah
you should be cheap labor funded right
yeah yeah okay
and I think that what you both presented
though is is sort of lightning
difference in regard to the kind of
networking and opportunity since you can
bring to people's right and it really
isn't just about Shanghai and Beijing
yeah yeah I think the markets big and
also you know every in every public has
their emphasis on different things also
I think the market is too big that you
know you can has many of us like many of
those pretty many of the SP is you know
they're a huge part to try to to fail
it's really because it's really for do
you have a decision to make do you want
to be a small fish in the ocean or a big
fish and about okay what about IP
so if a company comes to ghost agenda or
ghostess young is there an expectation
that they will provide IP to a local
partner there or what
so I think again you know it's a issued
say like right now in China IP go up a
lot also so I try to also write all the
focusing on that and also I think they
should definitely find like a u.s. you
know mothers who have both good in China
sighs so that that's how they can
protect the IP of us don't shop what
would you say it depends on if this is
Hart IP or soft IP so we talk about hard
I Pedro technology the cost of actually
infringing on somebody else's IP is
really big right now in China
I wouldn't recommend anybody doing it
even Chinese companies are very careful
all that you don't want to become big no
there are some soft IPS and questionable
things are nice business models things
are like form factor that's really hard
to protect even in US so I wouldn't even
say China as you need to a different
place so what stage was quark and when I
started considering it um they raised
about a hundred fifty million dollars
okay so they were already in phase two
they were they have a lot of dog and
savory okay but no but but at the time
I'm going back in history Oh two years
there they have amazing right and so you
are able to let bring an extra leverage
from Softbank
yeah they put in most of the funding we
read in own most part we only talked but
you were kind of a catalyst to help like
yeah have fun right yes so what were the
things that quark said that were because
they could have taken funding from
somewhere else right they could have
gone a traditional route here raise
another three hundred billion dollars
from some PE funds and or been bought at
that point it's not the money that
matters it's really about how do we
because course knows if everybody knows
they need partner but how do they know
they have one chance
and how they know who to work with that
they could be successful the way they
did it they talk to every pharmaceutical
Daria's in China they didn't ask them a
simple question have you ever done a
successful original class 1 drug taking
it from preclinical to phase 3 have you
done it but what was it spending the
time talking to China oh they want
Chinese market okay okay this is the
Chinese farmer market is going much
faster than us because we started the
foundation with much less lawyer okay
okay great um what's over before China
is run by the Chinese Communist Party
and I've noticed over the years of
various companies that I've looked at
that they either have a party committee
set up and them or their forces have a
party committee set up in them so at
what point dr. Wang your companies have
to set up a party committees and in fact
are you a member of the Chinese
Communist Party it's really good
question but I'm a little confused with
that question first of all I'm not a
part of Chinese Communist Party actually
I think I'm not good enough to be part
of it haha second I don't think you
really need a communist party committee
I don't either any company actually
absolutely sure I can comment on this a
little bit now let me comment if you
would change anything
is all about control and it's controlled
by the Chinese Communist Party it's a
fact of life
let being communist sure I was in the
back of the taxi with a gifted student
from one of the big universities in
China and I asked the student are you
going to join the party and the student
said it really depends on my job if I go
to work in the government I probably
will because the you have to be in like
the top 5% of your graduating class even
to get in right and if I joined the if I
joined the government I probably will
but if I go out and do it
probably not and it was remarkably
practical kind of attitude and in terms
of what's the party really going to do
for me
yes the party has a almost a shadow
organizational structure along with the
regular city government structure and so
on and so forth so that you do have a
lot of people who have dual positions in
both and so forth but I think that um
first of all if you're a foreign company
going into China you develop the local
expertise that will solve that problem
for you nobody goes into China
independently without having some sort
of a local partner and the issue of
going in you do it because you want
access to that market you also want the
kind of connections that they can help
bring to you in rest of world markets
increasingly partnering with China is
not about the China market
it's about partnering in Africa and
llamar in the rest of the world so I
think that this is one where yeah it's a
different system officially I don't want
to take a stand I have my own personal
preferences that we talked about
afterward but basically if you look at
it as a problem there are solutions and
you find the people who have the
solutions and you make sure that you
understand what you're getting into
that's the whole point and that's
exactly why we're we're trying to do
these programs George would you have
anything to say cause with all these
things from the cities sure the fines
all over this right yeah so for me I
might have one but my based on her she's
long as you deal with all the television
all that so I I don't really know this
yeah okay so you're from Taiwan yeah
okay alright and I think the one thing I
want to add too is we really focus on
businesses that create real value is
this the whole point of doing this is to
not think about how complicated the
environment with
is having a structure that enables you
as a founder to focus on value
generating product that's that's really
primarily why we did this in the first
place you can debate it later but I've
been doing business in China for 40
years I've got a slightly bored chain of
doing all of this okay buzz will come
back in the past in Chinese GDP has
really been exporter outwardly looking
and you talked in your remarks both of
you talked about how you're looking for
global markets okay what I'm wondering
about is is the you know recent stories
that have come out of China is the
transition China would like to make from
an export-driven economy which is more
like for Germany Japan Korea model to
the US model which is consumer driven
internally yeah right so can you kind of
comment on that and talk about your in
your pitch it seems like you're you're
trying to pick the Chinese Big Pharma
which would supply the world but that's
still kind of the old model of the
export as opposed to be more
self-sufficient one that's not as
reliant on the economic health of your
the people you're exporting to you want
it so what I see is basically you know
they they want to leverage or the
technology that you know the US and all
that that may help internally and also
with the new you know the one by one
ropes so they can actually do that you
know to you know the the whole the rest
of the Asia and also that so with that
they can actually and you know export to
other countries as well as the
technology event you know I think they
see Africa and also the other you know
countries wouldn't help you know with
all this technology that we have a
definitely internally you know they will
be the world consume more and also all
that I just want to add to that I just
China is very big I think we generally
content senses we all believe that
there's a huge rising domestic demand
that would be initial support you won't
be considering actually going global if
you're not really
in China but what happens really is
challenge there is competitive companies
who are really good at making money
already becoming successful in China are
really good at expanding out to probably
non-us now Europe territory because when
they go out they find out it's open
territory is much simpler to go there so
it's just something that is
straightforward when you have a good
battleground in China you want to
actually cut some more market out there
okay I love your gambit
I look you person then I think are
perfect okay
thank you ai is a section that a lot of
people are focusing leads on these days
and apparently China is getting very
serious about investing in in AI and a
lot of money is going into that sector a
friend of mine working at IBM too
recently got a new job focusing on open
AI and I'm curious how China views open
it so it's all about open innovation in
AI and how does China view that and are
you buying into open a out or is it more
good on they'll do it internally and not
necessarily pursue open innovation in a
sector that they are very serious about
and so what do you see happening in that
front yes I think right now you know
everything you put your food on a tie
you know everybody interesting I like
all the topics I'm a I just like I think
last year yes like two years ago you
know it's a are BR you know the VR you
know like when you go to see is
everybody's doing VR and then and now
look at it by almost all the company you
know and nobody not committed company
are doing we are now right so we see and
now it's like the next big you know
things they don't say we're talking
about but you want to see how you know
almost everybody walk on the street you
know everybody put a a on it but you
don't know whether they're really doing
it or not right but so you know so you
have to see how this thing's chronology
of course I think everybody focused on
trying to do AI as much as possible I
think open a I help innovation all that
you know I think definitely manual to
change somebody we talk to you know they
are
they want to do more on that but what
see how long this is laughs that's a
interesting word I just want to add to
what Georgia said so if you understand
if you go need consonants history five
years ago actually eight years ago
Henson and Baidu
and had this huge competitive
competition by the time they were Bulls
really really closed and and Alibaba as
well so and then a Ponemah who is the
founder of tension at the time felt the
pain of becoming really restricted and
private and closed out now you're facing
direct combat from everybody else it's
not part of your system so he had
decided to pivot $0.10 into a semi open
platform they specially started
investing outside of their companies
they started supporting developers they
start built api's we hadn't been really
open relatively speaking and that
started there so they change their
mindset and they build a Pingdom
periphery to Tencent business and they
were able to explore reach hacks for
finance for payment and that becomes 10
cent today which is much bigger than
everybody else so I actually like open
system it probably take time to be
entire extremely open but I think it's a
way that you go to defense system
outside of you man business if I can
comment briefly part of this is industry
evolution that doesn't have to do with
any country as a company gets to be
really big it realizes that to sustain
its growth it's better than support
developers who are doing third-party
applications and a lot of startup
companies so we're seeing that in AI you
know between Google tensorflow and and
Microsoft has one as your labs or
whatever and is on machine learning yeah
I mean everybody's developing this so
open is not necessarily free but it's
kind of industry evolution I think that
one of the things that again it comes
back to the IP thing in China with
companies like
$0.10 and Baidu and Alibaba you're
seeing
International using new MNCs
multinational corporations and so the
situation in China is how many more of
Chinese companies are really going to go
this international route and are they
really going to be people to partner
with for the startup companies here I
think there will be partner because it
because time is its most valuable asset
you don't have so I think the
transitioning of all of them are
acquisition happening lately is Chinese
company finally understand 'you could
accelerate with just paying money for
product okay gingka this one issue that
the Chinese government might try to
delay the approval of certain foreign
vaccines and medicines just try to make
extra time for local pharmaceutical
companies to come up with the sector
question but I don't think I know the
answer to that I don't know because it's
really hard to decipher it with case
studies and Chinese government really
trying to delay everything or it's
something happen in the process that
wasn't appropriately done it's really
hard to tell what's really happening
there but what I want to say is
supporting local entrepreneurs and
Chinese companies by the from the
Chinese government standpoint that's not
long they want to support their own
people they want to put resources to it
they want to encourage them to be
innovative doesn't mean you have to
suppress international enterprises that
I don't know but the fact that they are
trying to funnel more resources to
support local companies that it's all
this is not really wrong it's something
that US companies the government would
do it but okay good thank you Russians
call it off yeah the based on my
experience with my friends where my
classmates fear one impediment they had
in becoming entrepreneurs is the
opportunity cost you know be it can
comes employment opportunities or even
very bright minds they find it very
difficult to give up job opportunities
to go and pursue entrepreneurship in
your opinion have you seen this
happening in China is that an impediment
our people are saying okay you know what
we're gonna go big
I mean absolutely I think cultural
waiting 15 years ago starting your own
business is not something you'd be
respected I think what's really
respected job is you know becoming
professors universally becoming a doctor
culturally that's what my parent my
parents generation would support me to
do starting a company is only trendier
now because what's happening lately you
can provide value and there's our Giants
that demonstrated that definitely
there's issues related to not being able
to give up on security and start a
company can I follow through with that
because there's a certain trendiness to
places to write yes
so are you seeing that there's kind of a
feeling that if I'm not in Shanghai I'm
not in I'm not on Broadway I'm in some
regional theater I don't think I haven't
had trouble with people when you say you
know you're you really ought to come to
non-pom I think you know similar to silk
alignments a lot of advantages over here
but if you look on numbers of companies
that go out of other cities in u.s. it's
actually not true that only Silicon
Valley companies have advantages or
can't produce results I don't think
that's true when there is an advantage
there's a disadvantage I think
everything here is extremely expensive
you talk about Beijing oh my god that's
impossible to afford there are smaller
cities that got more advantages in that
respect so I don't see that you will be
you know having disadvantage there you
what kind of responses what do you say I
mean I think if you say let's go to Xian
what happens I think definitely you know
I think there are more role models that
you know the young people see now in
China
you can see all the 40 under 40 s orders
you know check my auto fix or you know
they're out there and you know I'm like
helping more in spoon or and all that
but definitely I think when young people
on 88 they are more other successful
entrepreneurs just like housing and
valid right like we are here we feel the
other you know like that point spoon ORS
and say hey if they can be a servant or
I can start our own company right and so
when you see that also in China is the
it's just it's like there are many
incubators also right so there are all
superstructures cursors to do to help
and also as you know we bring many of
the US company they're like they can
actually they want more US company to be
there so they can see how the other you
go watches success and so I I think
definitely you know maybe the big CD
says you know no more success because
you have to sweep because they see more
like like a tension is there you know
like agenda and all the big companies
are there you know they might be able to
see more like the u.s. going back people
compared with all the other smaller
companies I think definitely I think or
it is more bigger cities you know they
have more incubators there more people
hands-on us opening for Europe go back
and to contribute to the ecosystem to
help the people as well as you you can
have shallow other people who are you
going to a city to build this kinda like
an incubator you know all these things
otherwise if you just in a city you or
not it'll be hard for you to suggest a
there and success now one of the things
that it was kind of a strange mark is
whether there's a direct flight from
here to there yes and I was first to
find out but you know invited has direct
ties to change yeah III know they'll
have that earlier I don't know smaller
soon as you get better seats I look
forward to summer because we all like
I'm funky on we only got direct flight
from here to CN in the summer summer so
I would totally booked that because I
gotta great every time other questions
of economist okay for George Chow word
is puncture it into your spectrum of
opportunities so so we have health
council government promoter like the
competition here like a but we haven't
we haven't
I mean we cannot help the government to
without they're like the industry park
nor that but we haven't done
any kind of our conference there yet we
are doing talk with the government to
see how we can do more code I Alibaba
and financial a whole cluster of
combinations Jaguars busily building and
control yeah yeah I'm going to
definitely big for you know
intrapreneurship so they bring all the
actually I think the government take all
initiatives like you they have the
office here directly like though so they
don't mean you know like like us we
helping on that they had government here
office here actually they got they
actually they threw out the tools here
in the US to help companies go from here
to there you know directly so your
government is showing office crucial
yeah they volunteer yeah
and I'd also so that this asia-pacific
student entrepreneurship society right
one of their strongest chapters in
Hangzhou and they're giving an Asia
Summit nationally that's where you know
John University in Hangzhou yeah so not
on the government's really connected in
the US themselves like they hear a lot
and then they do all that them is out
there other questions or counters thanks
everybody
first of all thanks very much to Georgia
[Applause]